[Music]
where are we luca this is somewhere new
where could we be those are some new
sounds huh new noises new smell it's a
different kind of smell all right we are
at the airport and we are about to fly
to austin texas join the big boot girls
for a podcast shoot and for a special
event in austin where they invited
podcasters out for it it's a convention
so it's the con the podcast con yeah is
that a thing i don't know i actually
have no idea what the thing is but uh
tim's like oh we got invited out to do
something in austin we're going in
austin i'm like perfect now we got to
figure out how to travel with the baby
are you ready my boy we're going austin
yay
yeah i said i said that but then i was
like we're going to austin because and i
was like i have no idea what the thing
is called i just it's a con rtx rtx okay
so it's a podcasting and gaming
convention okay and we're meeting up the
big mood girl we're gonna do a panel out
there
and meet some of you guys super exciting
and then we're gonna go to dallas and
then go to orlando yeah it's a
three-part trip we're going to disney
world and universal like oh my god this
next two weeks is gonna be a whirlwind
like we are so ambitious with this trip
[Music]
i totally forgot to shave today oh you
brought your razor
joe it's packed away somewhere
[Music]
yes so ideal situation number one him
falling asleep throughout the entire
trip at the airport so far so good oh
that's not the goal no you want him to
be awake yeah i actually want him to be
awake right now go to sleep on the
flight so he's been awake for two hours
already this is nap time but his laps
are really short it sometimes sleeps
like 20 minutes i'm actually
very very very proud of the way i packed
everything i'll show you guys when we
open our luggage again because this time
i got packing cubes
and i had always avoided getting packing
cubes because i'm like i'm a pro already
i don't need an extra hand
no
they're helpful get packing cubes no one
but people with your brain appreciate
packing cubes the way you do
wait till i show you how it came out
like oh my god it's so beautiful i love
it the way you mention packing cubes
sounds like you're like i can't believe
i got this new car
i got a new tesla
yeah they are a big deal for
organization especially for packing
especially for pecking with a baby which
by the way today or tomorrow
is lucca's five months because today's
the first yesterday was the 30th he was
born on 31st so i don't know which one
do you think it was
the point is he's five months he's
flying for the first time on an airplane
at five months old
and his brother is gonna be flying solo
to dallas to meet us over there it's
gonna be a second time flying solo but
anyways yeah luka flynn at five months
that is fantastic and also yet very
terrifying i know
i'm so nervous with his life you're
ready to be stared at by a whole bunch
of strangers i don't care about that
okay are you ready to deal with the
constant screaming in your face what i'm
nervous about
[Music]
all right we're about to take off let's
see how zucca takes it like please take
the pacifier
because he just finished eating we were
sleeping for a long time
is that a good time so far
[Music]
he doesn't even know what's happening
is that funny
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
right here
he's a different kid
a little bit here and there like in the
times where it was like really intense
for years also our pilot was horrible
i've never felt like a roller coaster i
never had jesus
occurring he said no because he was
turning he was turning
[Laughter]
i'm like holding back the tears but he
did great he was laughing yeah there's
emotion right yeah
[Music]
we're in austin
let's see let's look around
this is your hotel room in austin
we got two beds what the heck i have in
here
uh-oh that's some limp gross
[Laughter]
these are the two places i've been yeah
look
why are you so lenti
i don't know that's me right
[Music]
roll around a little bit yeah yeah
that's totally me
dang it i love these pants yeah look
baby
we are in austin
yes
that's the first time we flew into
austin every every time your dad and i
have been here it's been via the car
mm-hmm it's always been a road trip
in london
it's a nice big texas-sized parking lot
though right yeah you won't forget
you're in texas because everywhere they
have texas
oh yeah let me see see if i can zoom in
on it can't miss it so big
yep it's one of those states where
uh they're very proud of their state in
fact i don't know if there's another
state in the u.s that's as proud of its
own state as i love new york everywhere
new yorkers
do new yorkers are new yorkers more
proud of being new yorkers or texans
being more proud of being texans lucas
first airplane ride was a success but
like i was saying earlier at baggage
claim i have never experienced that
amount of fear and anxiety on an
airplane in my entire life like i was
literally fighting back to tears because
it was so intense like i don't know like
the g4 is like he was like the pilot was
turning it was horrible it was horrific
so bad to the point where on the way
here i was talking to mama and i was
telling her i'm like wait i think i had
a panic attack like an anxiety attack
because afterwards like i was literally
like on the airplane like this like
holding luca and like stomping my feet
on in the seat because it was like so
intense and then afterwards it was so i
felt so dizzy that i was actually having
trouble breathing i was like
like oh my god that was intense and i
was trying so hard to not cry even he
was like trying to like calm me down
like oh it's okay like do you want me to
get luca and i'm like no i feel better
if he's in my arms like i've never
experienced that amount of anxiety in my
entire life on an airplane it was so
scary and then casey was like yeah i
think it do you think it might be
because you know you're fine look i've
never flown with a baby before isaac
isaac's first flight was when he was
three so i never did
fight with the baby and i don't know i
guess having luka with me and being in
my arms like it made me feel vulnerable
and like
i don't know scared and so with that
amount of turbulence and like g-force
and all that it made me really scared i
was so scared baby
meanwhile luke was having the life
he was laughing with the g-force he's
like
like it tickled him that was wild i'm
gonna tell jess all about it
because she can relate like there's only
one other person i know that actually
has panic attacks and like is in the
airplane
aware of themselves of having panic
attacks now i'm actually kind of nervous
because from here we're gonna drive to
dallas and then from dallas we're gonna
fly to orlando and orlando home so it's
two more flights longer flights too i
know those are long i don't know now i'm
actually nervous for these upcoming
flights i'm like what happened to my
brain like this is weird i don't know
who i am anymore like me having a panic
attack on an airplane what
you are so good look up
[Music]
so now we are eating uh tacos and they
well apparently they brought out the
wrong tacos we both ordered fish tacos
being tip and they brought our shrimp
tacos from one of us but you know mother
versus how he likes from tacos too so
they'll take it one on one
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god gina what happened i found
tiff's dry shampoo it's braided for your
mouth
what you're supposed to put on the roots
of your hair how did you get on your
face i might be three drinks in oh my
god
and i swear on my hair but i aimed it
wrong oh no
and now it looks like a token look at
this come here
i don't even know
you look like you got the donut
[Music]
she got into the donuts this is so funny
so we're gone look at my look at my
eyelashes it's just powder in my
eyelashes now
girl
oh my god
i look like i just spent a week in miami
during the 80s did we talk about this
we haven't blocked oh yeah
that's a hot mess right now subscribe to
all your fans okay
subscribe to my only fans i have white
stuff all over my face it's sprayed all
over my face i got sprayed in my eyes it
was a whole facial face shot yep uh dry
shampoo there we go cleared it up okay
so let's talk about this let's talk
about what's happening we are in austin
we're filming for our podcast the time
traveling wait what is it not time
travel i'm traveling that's my problem i
took a shot oh i guess with the
traveling pants podcast as a traveling
pant anyway so casey put the bed up so
we could set up the tripods we've been
filming we filmed two episodes so far
we're supposed to film four but we're
not gonna make it to the fourth one
because we have a dinner reservation an
hour and a half we still have to film
one more gina sprayed her whole face
with dry shampoo luca is with his
grandparents he's been next door and
we've been hearing him crying and i'm
like oh my god it's a torture like he's
okay he's okay he's okay but he has to
be with his grandparents it's been
really really hard i like i said i took
a shot with gina so i'm a little slurry
this camera did not focus on my face the
whole time it had happened i know i did
already it reflects like your mindset
there we go it's slurry
you got a couple drinks and like they
just see what you said exactly but it's
nice to be together in austin though
we're drinking oh yeah you took a huge
goal she gave me water gave us she gave
me vodka and sprites right which is
disgusting by the way yeah it's not that
great room temperature vodka sprouts
yeah it's not even cold we do have an
ice machine around the girls of ice
machine yeah i have ice in my cup over
here actually oh there we go i'm just
thirsty we gotta finish this episode
look at that it's 5 47 with our our
dinner reservations at 7 30 30 yeah we
gotta go
i got a drunk baby on my lap i don't
need to have any kids i'm not baby shirt
you're a drunk baby dry shampoo in your
face you're either drunk or a baby
for two minutes yeah two we left you
alone for two minutes who left the drunk
baby with an aerosol cannon exactly
that's terrible that's on us
all right get your butt in this chair
and let's film
[Music]
[Music]
baby luca
who's that
oh no
oh this is just cranky
it's not
[Music]
there's taxes um property tax giving him
headaches right income tax economy is
crazy try buying a house the only way to
pay for diapers right now toilet paper
expensive charming i like charmander
[Music]
we're eating some sushi some amazing
delicious mouth-watering
i don't think luke is intimidated
[Music]
hi mom and practice i'm not practicing
okay i just want to put the kid to sleep
so you can eat you're so full of it you
love this kid so much i hate kids
love them
you're such a mom you're doing a lot for
something you don't like
[Music]
you